[Music]
okay
now what does the sound sound like
probably sounds better because we had to
turn it we had to turn the microphone
down
i mean i don't know what the hell is
going on it's probably good
well you see it's not going into the
yellow or the red like it was before
yeah that microphone was going all the
way into the red before so we just
turned it down which is weird because
like i said i haven't touched anything
i just have no idea what is happening a
little weird but okay
a bit wonky but better khan says like
underwater
i don't know i don't know what to tell
you i don't know what's going on with it
i don't know mine sounds muffled we hear
you but it doesn't sound good
what the hell is the matter with it how
does it sound now
better it's got a slight echo it's a
little weird but it's a decent it's
coming through clear it must be pookie's
fault
kind of odd but i can deal with it yeah
there'll be some kind of an edit it's
got to be some kind of a
setting that's on well obviously but
it's like i haven't changed anything
that's what it does what it wants to do
it's a computer
you know that's that's what i said today
because it's not mechanical it's all set
up like i wanted and then i did a
recording today and then like i was
listening to it back and what the [ __ ]
does that sound like ass i never knew
that happened before
the parameters every time you [ __ ]
[ __ ] around with that computer
at all you don't talk about another
program that audio recording program
well that's it it's something like a
switch
well it is i don't know what it's doing
um
you'll figure it out you know i i don't
know i don't have any idea
it's just like saying they're saying
[ __ ] constant i'm conjuring white
noise puppets
not white noise poltergeist louis saying
that i'm [ __ ] doing too much juice
and [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] hasn't dude that [ __ ]
hasn't even kicked in it
it um week three it starts to come in
and then it doesn't plateau till like
weeks
week six so i'm still
i'm feeling better but i'm not you know
i'm gonna feel a lot better in about six
weeks
but three more weeks yeah in the
meantime it's not affecting you it's
just affecting all the
electronic equipment
it's not going to be super physiological
levels it's just going to be normal
levels
you know it's not it's not juice man
it's not like doing roids or anything
okay we got to get on this [ __ ] show
well just in case because i might get
rid of the last stream because we didn't
talk about everything
um so we wanted to say the regular show
yeah which is going to be about the
disappearance of db cooper this upcoming
week
i think we're going to do it friday
night instead of saturday we might start
moving
the streams to friday night instead of
saturday just because we're going to
start probably going out again on
saturdays
um so yeah so we'll probably move in the
show to
friday like i said i think at the end of
march i'm going to start i'm going to
keep doing the witching hour show like
up like through
march but then after that i think i'm
gonna stop doing it and then
do some more um like movie reviews and
stuff like that because i want to do
like some giant movies and [ __ ]
so i might try to do like one or two
more movie reviews a week
new new ones and old ones i don't know i
haven't really figured it out yet tila
just jumped in what's up
yeah [ __ ] lunch break yeah yeah he
says
hormones they found airborne yeah we saw
um
we saw uh coming to america again the
other day
uh getting ready for this weekend yeah
yeah sanders says senator says tomorrow
party stream is usually yes we are still
gonna do the wednesday night
right party stream at five probably talk
about
somebody asked us to do scariest horror
movie scenes which i talked about a
little bit last time but i'll get like a
more organized one
um somebody asked us to talk about kind
of the beginnings of
goth culture and music so we could talk
about that a little bit and we can talk
about the movie heat if you want because
we did
actually finally sit down last night
watch the whole thing yeah i saw
he was good masterpiece kind of like the
uh
kind of like the uh apocalypse now
[ __ ] cops robbers movie pretty neat i
hadn't seen it for such a long time i
think i saw it in the theater back in
the 90s but
i haven't seen it since then we'll talk
more about it all right so this new
movie we're going to be talking about
today
this is one that i just kind of chose at
random it's on amazon prime like a free
one you don't have to pay extra
and i had heard a couple people talking
about it had like decent reviews
so i started watching it it's a chinese
film
yeah uh called the lingering now
there's also a movie which i think we
reviewed months ago
that is on shutter that is also an asian
movie that is just called
lingering without the this is a
completely different movie than that
so just you know to become confusing
asian horror is all kind of samey this
one is a little bit different than the
other ones this one's a little weird
yeah i liked it it was good
real good real good soundscape real good
sound uh what do you call it
uh real good score you could you could
hear a lot of the shining where they
ripped off the shining in there but it
still worked it was good
it was good yeah this actually even
though it's listed as on amazon prime as
a 2020 movie i think it actually came
out in 2018
um but i guess they listed 20 20 because
that's when it got like a wider release
or whatever
the only thing that stood out to me that
was wrong with this movie is that
there's a scene where a ghost
comes uh into the room on hands and
knees like it's a
burnt up body and it looks really bad
yeah the cgi
looks like [ __ ] they probably should
have just like not i wouldn't even put
that in there bothered with it
because you didn't need it yeah it
should have been a damn something real
subtle like a
swirling swirling [ __ ] wind
or something you know some ashes in it
or something it didn't you know i mean
something
kind of invisible you didn't have to see
it seeing it made it worse
yeah this movie is kind of strange
because
i feel like i liked it but i feel like i
guess
like the dudes that directed and wrote
it this is their first
movie i don't even know if they made
short films like prior to this
and it's like it seems almost like two
or three different movies in one
you know what i'm saying yeah because
it's almost kind of like the first i
don't know like
third or half of it is kind of like a
pretty standard
ghost story i mean you have this woman
and uh she lives in this kind of
decrepit old mansion with her little boy
and i guess like they're waiting for
it's chinese new year i guess and
they're like waiting for
her husband to come home from work like
from the factory he never comes home and
then she keeps calling the factory and
they're just kind of like i don't know
leave me alone blah blah blah
and then dawa the kid starts
seeing what he calls a stranger uncle
in the house like he keeps seeing this
dude in the house who you're presuming
is a ghost
uncle yes because uh in korea and japan
and probably china
uncle just means old man yeah or oh man
they say
aunt and uncle yeah you don't really
know who it is which is funny because
somebody of that age you think that they
would just call them like grandma
grandpa
i like seeing dudes
yeah but yeah some dude in here so the
first part of it
is like a ghost story but then
the middle part of it jumps ahead 30
years
to when dawa is an adult and he's kind
of a douche
like even though he seemed like a
perfectly lovely little kid but now he's
kind of like a great dude he's like a
chef or something
and um so he gets called back to
like he's moved to the big city or
whatever and then he gets called back to
his old village
because they found the body and they
think it's his mom
so he has to come back and identify the
body even though he's i guess him and
his mom had become estranged in the 30
years
you know in the interim so he kind of
goes back there
and then there's like i don't know so
like the first part is kind of like a
ghost story
and then the second part there's some
ghosty [ __ ] in it but then there's also
some like scooby-doo
action and then it almost goes into like
a
like a heartwarming family drama sort of
like about the
relationship between a mother and son
and stuff like this it's very very
strange
it's kind of like i liked it but it's
really strange
and it was a little bit confusing i felt
like it was a little bit confusing
wait a minute a mansion in china is a
bit of an oxymoron does that mean
it's more than a three-room apartment
okay look
yeah it was like a big house but it was
like an old yeah i think
i think they said at some point that his
family had used to used to have money
but then they
lost a bunch of their money but they
still had the house but it was like kind
of depressing
there's a couple of these guys that i've
been interacting with that
lived in china for like 10 15 years one
of them
the channels are on youtube it's called
serpent za and the other guys named sea
milk but i don't remember the name his
channel is
and uh they they'll take you and show
you all the weird [ __ ] that was in
mainland china
and uh they married chinese women and
um no there's some wild [ __ ] in mainland
china there
there were fake cities built
how great is this right yeah okay i
didn't know what the hell that was
it's like hitting the glass over there
they have fake cities built like
housing uh housing complex cities
that look like copies of bavaria where
you had
castles in there but it was like a mick
castle
like the castle at disneyland is what it
was like yeah
it just wasn't a real castle of course
you know i mean just
the colors are [ __ ] crazy just
any some of those people want to own a
house anywhere but china but they don't
can't leave the
country so they'll build bavaria or
a fictionalized medieval [ __ ] france
you know what i mean
and [ __ ] if i had the money yeah
nobody ever buys them and they sit there
and they fall apart because china's
they have a bunch of real estate scams
going and they have a surplus of uh
housing and they'll have huge
skyscrapers they'll show them in there
man that's a really good channel it's
mainland china's bizarre but they'll be
these huge
skyscrapers of apartments and they've
been sitting there for 15 years
unoccupied falling apart
because they were built under some kind
of housing scam that they were running
for a while
it's just crazy but yeah check
yeah i was when i was watching the movie
i was like this is hong kong
taiwan or mainland china i think it
might be mainland china that's what
they're
what they're talking about but i feel
that it might be a hong kong movie
it might have been yeah it's like i
couldn't really find i mean there's some
info about it but not us
not a ton there's a there's a bunch of
bunch of cultural
memes and threads going through the um
through the movie that they're more
culturally relevant
uh revelling relevant to the chinese
like the whole thing is basically the
movie is about
being ashamed of poverty all right yeah
dude that's the whole meaning of the
movie dude's embarrassing of his mom
because his mom was a farmer and she's
poor
but she wasn't that poor you find out
later in the movie and then
he's he can't he he lies and tells
everybody that she's dead
to try to impress his urbanite friends
about how rich and successful he is but
he's a he's a fake
but they're all fakes too i don't think
he realizes it but they're not as rich
as they say
that they're saying that they are and um
in the end what the what what the moral
of the whole story was
is that the director is telling chinese
people that they gotta confront the fact
that their ancestors were poor
and that didn't mean that they were bad
people but if you look at the way china
is now just go
talk to serpents ea and see milk
all right you're supposed to be as rich
as you possibly can and as materialistic
as you possibly can
that's like a [ __ ] big that's like
it's all about
status but the thing is is that china
doesn't have the income forever to be
everybody to be like that so most of
them are faking fake and pretending that
they're
rich they're not rich you know making
ten dollars a day
that's what this movie is about it's
it's it's telling people to
confront the fit confront poverty
and to accept that your parents were
[ __ ] poor
but that didn't mean that they were bad
but that's an alien concept of chinese
evidently
yeah i did i definitely did get the
through line in there
like i said it almost kind of seems like
two or three different movies going on
at once yeah
yeah so it is a little confusing
these guys that have this other channel
they talk about their chinese wives they
marry these western dudes
and it's all about buying brand name
clothing and
fake fake designer stuff and they want
the real design they want the real
designer stuff but they have to buy the
fake designer
stuff instead and there's kind of like
this confusion between fake and real
like they don't realize that there's a
such thing as like fake gucci they
thought all gucci was gucci
it's just it's bizarre when you see
what's going on in other cultures
it's not like you expect korea was a
little bit like that when i was there
but it but from what they're describing
china is [ __ ] much worse
yeah that's what this movie is about i
don't know if you picked that up
yeah yeah i kind of got that yeah but
that's what that was about but um
i was gonna say there were actually some
really fun like i said the real estate
agent had was kind of like the comic
relief
yeah and that was one of his best i
don't know this is exactly what he said
obviously because i don't speak mandarin
chinese but um
this is what the closed captioning said
was that i guess he was trying to like
scare somebody away
or scare the owner so he would sell the
house or whatever and he said something
like
i guess i guess they'll need additional
terror
i was like additional terror i want to
start a band
called additional error that's [ __ ]
rad and it was also like a [ __ ] great
line i think dawah says it one
you know the grown up says it they're at
some like hotel
or whatever and it's a smart hotel and
then he says something like
in in china or in whatever city they
were in it's like even the smart hotels
are [ __ ] he said that
and um also when they first introduce
adult dawah like he wakes up from what
you think is a nightmare
and he's in bed with his girlfriend and
he says to her
he's like oh i had a dream i dreamed you
and then she was like what
i dreamed you gained 30 pounds i was
like
wow what a dick
[Laughter]
so that's how they introduced so they
showed that he wasn't like the nice
little
i saw a video of about a 985 pound
chinese girl at the bmw dealership
in a mall somewhere in an absolute
fury in the security campus jump it up
and down because our old man's credit
card won't clear because she's trying to
buy this [ __ ] bmw
and when they they did they turned her
down like three or four times and she
backed up and did a flying
run just a flying leap over the damn
balcony of a [ __ ] five-story drop
right on video cameras yikes she's like
21
22. like a 21 year old chinese
chinese trophy wife just jumped off a
damn balcony
five-story drop well you know she was
like
she just couldn't take it anymore
[Laughter]
it was like it was a huge mega mall yeah
it was indoors
she jumped off got her on the video on
the security camera just [ __ ] nuts
that's pretty damn materialistic yeah
that's very mature
this shit's not clear this shit's not
clear
it was famous man [ __ ] was going around
i guess it was about six seven
six or seven years ago oh yeah yeah
somebody asked if you had seen poseidon
with kurt russell
oh man oh that was that was uh
was it a remake of the poseidon yeah i
think that's what he's talking about
beside an adventure oh okay
no i didn't see it fourth pronoun says
i've never wanted a bmw that badly yeah
either i mean i i can't really think of
anything i'd want badly enough to jump
off a five-story building if you're
gonna
if you're gonna kill yourself i i
wouldn't kill myself that way just
because one i'm scared of heights and
two i don't want somebody have to
like scrape my bloody ass off the
[ __ ] pavement that's not
yeah [ __ ] crazy shackles and she
didn't have any history of mental
illness or anything like that she was
just spoiled
spoiled and [ __ ] lost it yeah
momentarily just got frustrated yeah
you're dead
good job imagine that
yeah well [ __ ] like i said i can't
imagine
crazy yeah that's crazy
that said i was about to get a full
camera at a burger king yeah yeah
i've seen some people go full carrying
at my time not so much that they jumped
off the building that's that's that's
expert level karen right there but
i'm just like [ __ ]
so uh yeah amanda says when i lived in
korea students used to kill themselves
by jumping
out of buildings all the time just
because of the stress that school there
got to them yeah
i can see that like i can see how
stressed we get to it's just i don't
know i i just wouldn't choose
it's kind of like how back in the old
days i feel like well not even
back in the old days but i i wrote about
a lot of cases where
people would kill themselves by firming
themselves in front of trains
it was like a big thing for that like
especially back in the uk like back in
the
late 19th century and i was just kind of
like
why why would you choose
to kill yourself that way because not
only
does somebody have to clean your ass up
also you're stressing out
everything like the dude that's you know
driving the train
and everybody that was on the train and
now they have to all get out and they
have to scrape your [ __ ]
bloody carcasses maybe drugs
well yeah once you do that at least you
just kind of like lay in your bed
maybe you barf or something people would
throw themselves out in front of horses
and carriages and they and the horses
just step over them yeah that carriage
would run over and it would kill you
um you know probably hard to get guns in
england at that time and [ __ ] jumping
off of a building man you gotta [ __ ]
scream all the way down
is not as [ __ ] cool as people think
it is especially if it's misapplied
you know well it depends on what kind
depends on what it is but because
usually it's death by suffocation it's
not quick yeah
or you're death by [ __ ] vomiting and
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] lungs
[ __ ] in your lungs i would rather do
that than get hit by a [ __ ] dream
if you [ __ ] want to do it oh i don't
want to say that because
somebody might [ __ ] do it
and you know ways that don't mean that
somebody has to clean your splattered
ass off of your
public property you know yeah
alcohol it seems a little selfish
alcohol
directly into your system in a few
minutes
of time where the the the liver and the
kidneys can't cope with it will kill you
yeah and it's not a wouldn't be that bad
of a death you just
pass yeah because you just get really
drunk and you just wouldn't wake up
that's right
you know right louis asked what you
thought of the shootout scene in heat
well which one there's a couple of them
you must be talking about the bank
robbery
probably i'm assuming that's kind of
like the best one yeah it was pretty
cool i mean
they're never really realistic you know
i mean you can't really hide behind cars
assault rifles you know because right
the sheet metal of a [ __ ]
car you know five five six or seven six
two thirty nine
which is what an ak shoots or five five
six what a what they were shooting i was
um they were kind of hiding behind
things that you can't hide behind
um there was a bunch of cops there
shooting at them
they had been with they'd have been
there's something called withering fire
which is just so many people shooting at
you
even the even the misses are [ __ ] up
um it's like
raindrops coming at you they all would
have been killed
under what they showed but it was
exciting to watch in the movies
that's just movies yeah
yeah i mean you know very rarely do they
show do i ever see any
firefights in a movie that look
realistic to me
well the thing about it though is that
you know you can't put necessarily like
real realistic [ __ ] in movies because
it doesn't work it doesn't look
cinematic you know there's not
any drama or something like that watch
gun camera footage and [ __ ] like that
from those
from the wars in the middle east and
you'll see what they really look like
they're not real
they're not real impressive um but
you know you can see boats going through
people and [ __ ] blood splatter
[ __ ] like that people's heads [ __ ]
vaporizing pink [ __ ] smoke when a
bullet goes through them it's just
you know and uh a lot of times people
kind of pinned it down
under fire and they're shooting in one
direction because they're underneath
cover but somebody
gets them from another angle just it's
not a lot of running
if you get up and run you just cut the
pieces usually it's just
look at gun cabinet footage you'll see
yeah
and what's going on now you know a lot
of the a lot of the footage i see coming
out of
iraq or afghanistan the past few years
to me that doesn't look like combat at
all it's just guys right riding around
or walking around until somebody shoots
at them
and then jumping out on the ground do a
lot of yelling and running around
shooting into the bushes they don't ever
see the guy
it's just one guy took a pot shot at
them
[Laughter]
formation or anything it's just a dude
in flip-flops
with a with a [ __ ] shirt that looks
like a skirt
a shirt dress and a little hat
and he takes a shot at you and before
you
drops to the ground and he runs off you
know you didn't even see
video footage of their engagements yeah
uh first first and three two seven
uh first in the 506. they'll post it and
i i'd go it would that [ __ ] would get to
me
it would make me [ __ ] it would just
be very frustrating because they're just
fighting ghosts
this is law enforcement yeah
scott's asking what's going on with the
sound yeah because i guess you just got
here um we're having like some audio
issues i have no idea what it is
um so i'm gonna have to after this ends
i'm gonna have to
yeah figure out what the problem worried
about what the problem is because i
don't because
you know i mentioned earlier that i was
making a video earlier like i was
recording
and then i listened to it back and it
sounded like ass and i don't really know
why
um so yeah we'll have to get it sorted
out
before the party stream tomorrow because
i don't want that sounding like [ __ ]
butt all the whole time you know it's
getting an echo i don't you know i don't
know
you know what i might do is i might just
take this obs i might like take
everything out of it and just like
[ __ ] start over
because there might be some kind of
problem somewhere yeah who knows
like i said i don't have any ideas i
come in here and i had everything set up
and then all of a sudden it just started
changing things like willy-nilly without
me doing it so
i don't really know it's goose
but yeah so i guess we'll uh kind of cut
this short because i'm nervous about the
stream going and i'm kind of pissed
about the audio being [ __ ] up and i
really want to figure out what's wrong
with it
so you know we mostly talked about the
movie like it's on amazon prime
if you have amazon prime it's free it's
a chinese movie
we're turning the mic down even more how
does this sound better
yeah the mics down a little bit lower
maybe did you
look at the volume on here i don't know
i put it down
yeah i don't know why who knows i don't
know um
so yeah so tomorrow uh at
5 00 pm eastern standard time we're
going to do our
party stream like i said we'll probably
talk about the movie heat more than
talk about a couple other things that
people have requested
so uh yeah that'll do it for our matinee
today
you have anything else you would like to
add um they're asking they're still
asking about those gun fights
when i remember a movie that it looked
pretty realistic
um it was one i haven't seen it forever
i have to see it again hamburger hill
i remember that one yeah i remember that
seemed pretty realistic
um saving private ryan had some parts in
it that were pretty realistic for that
era um
although you know what's funny is that
they show tanks and aircraft and [ __ ]
german infantry and everybody fighting
all in the same intersection
that's like some [ __ ] you see out only
out of a movie or some kind of a
recruitment
poster you never see any more than one
kind of enemy at a time
you see the helicopter and then four
days later oh you saw
some dudes and then three weeks later i
think we saw
them a rocky half track or something you
know what i mean
but it was a mile away the battle space
is [ __ ] huge and the units are put in
different areas it's usually
you usually don't see anything you don't
see everything all in one shot
they're doing that for the camera yeah
yeah um
yesterday no actually we lost the stream
yeah that's what happened
yeah i didn't mean i was i was trying to
like i was kind of like i was like oh no
it's gonna crash it's gonna
i'm going to have to start over and just
clean everything out and
see what the [ __ ] is going on with this
because i don't know so it says just
sounds like you're in the bathroom yeah
like that's what my recording sounded
like
all right so uh we will see you guys
tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern standard time
for us
weekly sidetracks party stream and uh
thanks everybody for dropping by bye